this is a brand new enemy called a
construct
we'll fight it using the branch we just
picked up
ah the branch broke not good not good
quick get another branch and
we defeated it
moving on
[Music]
we've now explored more of this Sky
Island
as expected fighting with just a branch
won't get us very far
also this branch is almost broken so
here's another one of Link's new
abilities if we use this branch and the
rock over here and do this look we can
stick them together we created a
makeshift Hammer this is called fuse you
can stick objects together to create new
weapons with various effects let's take
on another construct with this fused
weapon
we're dealing with two of them at once
oh we beat one
the weapons attack has definitely
improved
the other Branch broke but this weapon
has much better durability
you can do all sorts of things by
experimenting with the fusibility
you confuse two weapons for example if
we take this long stick and fuse it with
a pitchfork
we can create a weapon with a much
longer attack range
with this we don't have to get too close
to enemies and we can safely attack from
a distance
you can also fuse Arrows with materials
in your inventory
for instance try fusing this Leaf to an
arrow
foreign
fuse an ice Elemental material to an
arrow and
you can freeze far away enemies
very useful
in addition
let's see
ah there's a bird flying around if
you're out hunting you might feel that
aiming with an arrow is too difficult
apparently my eyes can't track fast
moving objects as of late so my shots
rarely land
so at times like these
here's an eyeball you can get by
defeating monsters
fuse it to an arrow and
look it homed in on the target
let's try this on another bird
I'll just fire in that General Direction
that's very simple
depending on what you stick together the
fusibility could also be beneficial for
hunting
I fused a mushroom to my shield
now you're probably wondering if this
has any use well this mushroom is
actually a puff shroom
let's fight an enemy with this
I blocked with the shield
okay there's smoke now the enemies lost
sight of links so attack
even if you struggle with combat you can
take down enemies using similar methods
in the previous game you'd usually get
powerful weapons by defeating strong
enemies but in this game fusing even the
weakest weapon with something else could
turn it into a useful weapon there are
even more gameplay options for sticking
things together let me demonstrate
some of the sky islands even have Rivers
we'll want to cross this one but
swimming across it well the river's too
wide for that we need a boat
of course there isn't anything that
resembles a boat around here
so we'll lift up this log and attach it
to a second log
let's do one more we'll bring this over
here and attach a third log
it's a makeshift raft this is another
new ability called Ultra hand
even though the logs are currently
attached they can be detached let's
modify the shape of the raft
you can always attach things or detach
them like this
now if we put this on the water it's
made of wood so the buoyancy will keep
it afloat
we've made a simplified version of a
boat
however it won't move in its current
state so we'll need something to propel
it forward
there's something here let's try hitting
it
oh a wind it's blowing wind
looks like we found a fan why don't we
try attaching it
we'll attach another one
this should make the boat well balanced
okay they're attached
all right let's try moving the boat
hey it's moving
it's sailing pretty fast with the Wind
from the fans
since we added two fans we should be
able to cross the river in no time
all right we reached the other side
in the most recent trailer we showed
scenes of Link riding a large car and a
flying machine
those Vehicles actually aren't in the
game from the start instead you'll be
able to freely craft them on your own
there are all sorts of objects you'll
come across in this game and depending
on how you use your imagination you can
do a lot with them so try crafting
different things and explore this world
at your leisure